Alexis in your bio it says that you are
or you were excuse me a former editor
for the poetry webzine brink and
wondering how did that come about and
then what lessons did you take to that
that you've now brought to your creative
career well it's funny with bring it
came about through that similar spirit
which I think has helped me to move
forward my creative career which was I
thought it would be a good idea I wanted
to do it and so I just did it there was
one other element which was quite lucky
this was back in them it was kind of the
first couple of years that the internet
started getting known in the UK anyway
and because of my technical abilities I
was able to write the code for this for
this internet web page you didn't have
web page designers back in back then so
I had to write web code and there
weren't many poets around but I don't
know their earlier out there they were
one or two there was a kind of community
on the internet but it was mostly by
email so that there weren't many poets
you could write computer code so that's
how that came about is I could do that
and I had this idea for what's called
hyper poetry which I won't go into but
I'm now quoted in some academic tax as
one of the first example of a hyper poet
but really it's not worth talking about
as a technical point but if anything
brink taught me about that if you just
do something and its innovative and it's
interesting and it's got quality people
will notice it will it will get noticed
but I'm not for a long time it took a
long time for bring was kind of and my
relationship to hyper poetry was noticed
so I've learned since then that
publicity if you like promotion is very
important and it's quite a it's the game
of publicity if you like a lot of people
do it badly and it's frustrating
sometimes have to be careful what I say
hear about their you know journalists
and everyone the People v this imagine
bunch of people
on the other end of the email on the
other end of the phone call who are
stopping you from getting what you want
or you're stopping you from getting your
message out the public or whatever
they're just busy people trying to do
their job try not to upset their boss
you know and they they need to be you
need to capture their interest and if I
email journalists the subject line of
the email has to be mind-blowing you
know it has to have something it's
either got to be mind-blowing I mean if
it's something like you know Britney
Spears falls down dead in the middle of
the street in the subject line it
doesn't need to be I mean is actually
mind-blowing Britney Spears does
anything yeah then then that's going to
be like they'll open that email but if
it's a Lexus cook they're not going to
over the year oh I have got to put
something else in there you know it's
something like technically I've been
lucky the projects that interest me tend
to be quite unusual because of my
fascination with the Arts and
fascination with the sciences so the
trick has been wording it so for example
the film that i made i think one of the
reasons they've got a lot of publicity
was not necessarily the content of the
film it was the byline i came up with
which was a film that watches you while
you watch it and such you know that a
few words has made a difference to my
film career you know as a result of that
I think significantly as a result of
that maybe not entirely because of that
but I got stuff in in India and IMDb and
all you know national public raging or a
lot of national and international press
about the field not the content of the
film but the concept of the film and I
really think that by line for a busy
journalist they can just read that at
the top of the press release read it at
the top of the email and am
you